Bren Fraser working with him and I know
you did this you know it aired on Warner
Brothers and it was this stuff you did
in South South Africa and was dangerous
and a lot of guns and this team of uh
you know assassins or whatever FBI or C
CIA stuff whatever but something like
even doing something like that could you
see the talent he had in just the small
time that you had working with him yeah
so he played a charact character who on
paper my character was supposed to be
you know his his character pays me to
protect him and my character doesn't
like this guy he doesn't like what he
stands for and moment to moment on set I
saw the Brilliance of Brendan where I
was
fighting not liking
him like I'm not supposed to like this
guy but his angle on the character was
so just like it was annoying to be it
was annoying so I'm like I'm not
supposed to like you and so what
happened is it bled into
the the connection between the
characters which I think became sort of
like a not Butch Cassidy Sundance but it
was like a you could see my character
being ground down by this guy's agenda
and I think him and I just we we didn't
like hang out after said or do any of
that but onset he has this thing of
bringing you in and he's so engaged and
he's so so such a beautiful person I
think that's literally how and when I've
seen him a few times since like at at
cons and stuff he's just beautiful he's
just
so wonderful